hey 42 here in 2012 the Advertising
Standards Authority ordered a North
Hampton based furniture store in England
to stop advertising its prices are so
low welcome to RIF China is the
world's largest supplier of Bibles one
Factory in Nanjing prints a million a
month 10% of us electricity is made from
dismantled Soviet atomic bombs over a
hundred billion neutrinos pass unnoticed
through your head every second the Queen
is the legal owner of 1/6 of the Earth's
land surface there are enough diamonds
in existence to give everyone on the
planet a cupful if you scaled a snooker
ball up to the size of the earth
it would have Mountain 3 times higher
than anything currently on the planet
everybody expected the Spanish
Inquisition before they arrived because
they were legally obliged to give 30
days notice George W Bush and Saddam
Hussein had their shoes handmade by the
same Italian cobbler collectively humans
have spent longer playing World of
Warcraft than they have existed as a
species separate from chimpanzees humans
have collectively racked up five point
nine three million years of Wow the
first advertising jingles were written
down in newspapers readers were expected
to sing them themselves thanks for the
view subscribe for more 42
you